do you know what we're gonna do
there yeah over here
[Music]
this is the world's
biggest ferris wheel it's
550 foot tall it's actually not even a
ferrous wheel it's actually considered
an observational wheel that's nine feet
taller than the last highest ferris
wheel how do you feel about it because i
know you're afraid of heights i know
well i look at it and it's moving kind
of slow so slow and gradual and i
thought it'd be super cuny because i've
been to the london eye before marvel
hasn't been to london eye so we've never
done anything like this together plus we
got a third guy now but this guy is
slightly scared of heights you go this
one yeah then you're going that way are
you worried because i know you're kind
of scared of heights
what do you think do you think he's
scared of his i have no idea i thought
he is for certain things i think he's
gonna be scared and then he surprises me
and he doesn't even mention it so i'm
like i have no clue no clue whatsoever
so we're about to get lost in the
world's biggest ferris wheel
[Music]
all right so the part that i already
enjoy about this is the convenience
factor because i'm a big convenience
person um so you can buy the tickets
right outside so as you can see to my
right we have a big
it's not a ferris wheel observational
wheel what is it called yes but then off
to this side
that's where we buy our tickets so it's
all self-service i'm all about that so
all ready
[Music]
true what about you i know recently
you've been more risky at first i know i
think this is so slow now i don't think
so really
watch me go like i gotta get out of this
i don't know i have no idea what you
feel i know me neither because i think
i've been going the opposite of you
where i was really scared of heights but
slowly it's been dying down i've been
more of a [ __ ] and you've been less of
a [ __ ]
all right let's go let's go let's go
monkey oh wait first let me use the
restroom just in case i don't know how
long this ride is 30 minutes
whoa okay yeah
[Music]
[Music]
this is so cool we got one to ourselves
are you having fun and let him pick the
negative emotion if he even has one
are
you yes
yes
get closer come closer
[Music]
look like this look
[Music]
[Music]
we're not even at the
so this supposedly is the highest view
that you can get of vegas without being
in a helicopter which is cool because
i've always wanted to get like a bird's
eye view of vegas because you know it's
not just the strip there's also the
climate the desert the landscape and
they say during the sunset is the best
time to do it
but i don't think we would have had a
private
pod like this
and also one other thing that's super
cool this thing's so huge it took over
seven million pounds of steel to create
this thing
million pounds of steel
and i'm happy the more steel the better
keep us safe i don't want i don't want
this to be shaky like crazy
oh yeah
it's sturdy
this is absolutely terrifying really i'm
trying not to think about the seven
million the pounds of steel i'm trying
to think about anything i'm trying to be
like
we're okay
[Applause]
i think so so let's not talk about what
i'm actually experiencing until i'm on
the ground safe and then i'll tell you
everything i'm talking about
yeah
let's look at the views
all right so i think we're about halfway
up and what helps me gauge that is
that's the middle spoke right there so
it often comes eye level with the middle
spoke anything after this
we will slowly be getting to the apex of
the sun
[Music]
all right guys in like 30 seconds we are
about to be at the apex of this wheel
so right now we're right behind that box
getting lower
we're getting higher
and that one
oh my god
i think we're at the peak
and the sweaty butt crack that i have
right now it's beautiful it's gorgeous
it's breathtaking look at the bellagio
fountain what's happening
now
not like i was speaking to myself back
there
um
i think i just have to not focus on
death yeah and when i stopped
focusing on death then i was able to
really enjoy it i was like looking at
everything me and tech were playing
games like spotting different cars and
stuff yeah um so that was nice
so yeah
okay here we go
oh
all right so we just finished the high
roller
one thing that i discovered about vegas
that i was like oh wow i didn't realize
this is i know vegas is in the desert
but i didn't know that we were
surrounded 360 by mountains me neither
that was crazy
what did you discover monkey monkey what
did you like about the ride
i think he was just counting the pools
and the pizza and the water the whole
time that's all i care about what about
you is there anything that was
unexpected for you that you're like what
um besides discovering how scared of
heights you are i think i had this
revelation that i've always been afraid
of heights but my whole life i've always
uh suppressed that because i wanted to
enjoy the experience with my loved ones
yeah so i always kind of put that aside
and i was like i kind of liked it a
little bit but i think now that i'm
older i'm more like oh i don't know if i
like it but i realize when i don't think
about it and i focus on like a task or
playing games or just not focusing on
the death part of it then i have a
really good time and i'm really happy
that i did this i highly highly
recommend it but i would say come around
sunset or nighttime so you can enjoy it
way more let's say they're scared of
heights i just don't recommend it yes do
it anyway it's very safe this is the
safest it's going to be do it that's
true so if you guys are in vegas and you
want to get a top-down view of the strip
the desert the climate all that stuff
make sure you go check it out it's high
roller it's right next to the link
venetian 550 feet in the air or if
you're just looking for a 30 minute very
air conditioned cool break from walking
around on the strip come check it out or
if you have a crush
on someone and you're like oh how do i
get to know them better at least you
have 30 minutes with them where you're
trapped i like that idea
thank you guys for following us as we
get lost in this world see you guys next
time